firstly we're going to use this first
principle thing to work out the gradient
function okay
now just to quickly remember I said to
you then I first introduced this guy f
dash of X or F Dash for short a issue is
this guy to help us use your all of
these limits and what have you and then
I said as an alternate E is you'll see
this guy dy/dx okay they refer to same
things the gradient function in this
context I'm going to use this one and
not this one because have a look at the
question the questions provided to you
in function notation it's got an F
defined in so therefore I'm going to use
the notation which has an F in it if on
the other hand the questions first line
was not f of X equals if it was y equals
then I would use D 1 the X notation
because there's no F since I'd so you
can't really talk about f dash X right
so if you're wondering about like well
which one do I use they do mean the same
thing but just have a look pay attention
to what they've been um what's been
provided to you and then just follow
with that okay
secondly I define this as the gradient
function gradient functions but another
name you will see for this and your reef
of this is the derivative the derivative
okay why do you think it's called birth
derivative what is it like when you say
something is a derivative from something
else what does that mean I generally
means wrong it comes from like you've
got this thing right you've got cane
sugar and then or so you've got your
sugar head and then you've got raw sugar
which is a derivative from that you
start from here you do some stuff to it
and then you end up with this product
okay that's what the derivative is it
comes from there
so this process we can now launch into
it the first thing I'm going to write is
the first thing I'm going to write is
they'll live it because why because I'm
interested in that cage it not the
secant so go ahead
down at this point while you're first
still getting it into your head I think
you should write down the first full
line of first principles which is this
guy every single time until such point
as you no longer need to write it and
you can still successfully do the next
line without really thinking about it
like I said this is on your reference
sheet but I don't want you actually
having to constantly refer to that but
such a foundational result I think you
guys are well capable of actually
learning it and memorize you just by use
so again I write the limit and now I'm
going to evaluate this for this
particular function so everywhere I see
X I'm going to put in X plus h for the
first thing okay so it's going to look
like this that thing in the square
brackets that is f of X plus h you can
see all the x's have been replaced and
then by definition you can see on the
end there don't forget
excuse me you've got subtraction so
watch out for the sign that's an easy
thing to get wrong it's not x-ray of
minus 4 it's going to be after I explain
expand these brackets it's going to be x
squared plus 4x right so just watch out
for that all of that is divided through
by H ok now just like in our simple
example that we did first stop if I
expand this out and do it correctly I
ought to have a whole bunch of things
canceling out right so let's have a go
up the top here I've got this guy just
like I had before I'll expand that ok
what I get on the right minus x squared
plus 4x that's all divided by H and if I
did it quickly let's have a look this is
going to cancel with that that works
that's checked out and then what else we
got this guy is going to cancel with
this guy you're happy with that this is
one of the ways that you will know that
you did it correctly for all the other
questions you'll get this nice neat
carefully thing happening so what
remains after of course you write the
limit what remains on the numerator all
you got
2x h plus h squared minus 4 H did I get
them all yep that's all divided through
by H one last time I will evaluate the
limits
so I'll write a limit rather 2x plus h
minus 4 by the way do put brackets
around it that limit applies to all of
your terms not just one of them so
you've got the brackets around there and
so now you can say this is going to be 0
sorry that's a ya know so that's that's
2x 2x plus 0 minus 4 yes
so there is my gradient function I got
there okay or my derivative
now just and make things even more
confusing this process that we've just
gone through to find the gradient
function to find the derivative this
process we call now just pause there's a
totally logical thing that would come
out of this word that you would think
this is called but it's not bad
this process is called differentiating
please never say that you are deriving
because you are not deriving driving is
something completely different and I'm
not going to start an argument about my
frustration with the word derivative
differentiating is what you have just
done which is why you will never achieve
me use the word differentiation which is
this process to talk about when you're
telling things apart you know you are I
want to differentiate between this guy
and this guy right I never used that
word because it means this to me I use
the word distinguish when I want to talk
things apart so congratulations you have
just differentiated this function now
you know it's gradient okay or its
gradient function now have a look at
question 3 they ask you to do a series
of things with this gradient function
the first thing is use the derivative
that guy to evaluate F - 2 F - 2 now
what does this mean I'm going to find
the gradient at x equals 2 does that
make sense
I'm going to substitute
like so don't skip that step by the way
and what's that equal to that's zero
that's convenient
okay so now I look at that and I say
find the y coordinate of the point P on
this function where x equals two so
think about this room in right you just
work out the gradient at two now you
want to know the y-coordinate at two so
I'm going to work out F of two not F
dash or two but F of two so I go back
all the way to the original function
that's going to be two squared
now what's that negative four so I've
got a gradient I've got a y-coordinate
I've also got the x-coordinate think
about that x coordinate y coordinate and
a gradient those are the three things
you need to find the equation of a line
and they're just way you can see what
we're up to now part three find the
equation of the tangent at P right so if
P is at two comma what have a look at
what we just worked out negative four
there's the corner there and I know the
gradient at T because P is at x equals
two right
it's zero that's all I need to find the
equation of the tangent at page
by the way you really should write
something what some words maybe not this
many words but at least tell me you're
finding the tangent on this next line
when you say something like this y minus
y for say y1 have any letters and
numbers in my head
y minus y1 equals M outside of X minus
x1 don't skip that please I know you can
see oh that's not going to become
something important it's going to come
trivial but I'm recognizing here look at
looking at you're working and I'm seeing
that you know what you're doing here
right this of course is equal to does
that make sense
have a look what would this thing look
like to draw a super messy sketch of
this x squared minus 4x where the
intercepts going to be 0 and 4 right 0 &
4 it's just the concave up parabola like
that right x equals 2 if that's 0 & 4
where's x equals 2 what's the
significance of x equals 2 do this it's
the axis of symmetry isn't it it'll be
there so I want the or what I've found
is the equation of the tangent at that
point where the movement of this object
which is this why is it this it's just
the just a horizontal line down here is
the face of that there you go okay so
you see what you've done do you see what
you're done use the gradient function so
that anywhere along this curve you can
find out what the gradient will be and
then you test it at a particular spot
which they labeled paint and that gives
you the equation of the tangent